salut aujourd'hui je vous parle depuis
mulhouse depuis l'entrepôt théâtre à
mulhouse où je joue ce soir demain et
après demain la vidéo doit sortir à 17
heures il est exactement 16h05
je suis bien bien dans le timing comme
il faut le jeudi c'est le jour de je
parle de ce que je veux mais cette
semaine petits changements je vais
parler de ce que vous voulez vous et
depuis hier sur facebook twitter et
youtube vous est demandé à thème pour
cette vidéo là à partir du moment où
c'était pas une astuce sur un truc de
mentalisme j'ai eu de très très bonnes
idées que je garde pour toutes plus tard
mais que je peux faire qu'à partir de
chez moi et ce matin à marie géante qui
m'a fait mourir de rire en disant t'as
qu'à parler de comment on fait quand on
oublie une valise dans un train puis
parce que l'année dernière j'ai fait
même car que ça j'ai mis ma valise dans
le mauvais train j'ai eu de sortie du
train pour téléphoner le train est parti
et il n'allait pas du tout à part il est
allé à nantes
ça m'a fait une connexion dans mon
cerveau quand on a parlé de trains et de
mulhouse à l'entrepôt théâtre la
première fois que je suis venu jouer à
mulhouse j'ai oublié mon mac dans le
train et je les retrouver et je pense
que cette histoire va vous intéresser
faisait donc le trajet paris mulhouse en
train avec mon diffuseur on était tous
les deux avec joachim dans le train et
on était tous les deux l'un à côté de
l'autre je regardais l'ordinateur j'en
ai eu marre j'ai éteint l'ordinateur
gelé mis sur le filet devant moi arrivé
à mulhouse on nantes annonce joachim
française à faire je récupère aussi ma
sacoche mon manteau ma balise et nous
v'la descendus du train direction
l'entrepôt théâtre je commence à fermer
balance sur scène installé le matériel
pour jouer le soir je me rends compte
que j'ai laissé le mac sur la première
place où j'étais précédemment dans le
filet comme un imbécile je les oublie
question comment on fait pour retrouver
un mac dans ces circonstances dans un
premier temps joachim et sarah sera-ce
elle appauvrit les terres de l'entrepôt
sont partis tous les deux à la gare pour
aller voir si on avait déposé le mac aux
objets trouvés
évidemment que dalle j'enclenche le
localiser mon mac sur mon iphone permet
comme ça de le localiser ces affaires de
plus ou moins près et de faire
apparaître un message double
verrouillage à distance ou de l'est face
à distance à condition qu'ils de la
batterie et qui se connecter au wifi
c'est une toute petite minute avant que
le spectacle commence
je reçois une notification il vient de
passer à côté d'un réseau wifi que je
connais peut-être un réseau free est à
ce moment précis je sais que mon macbook
pro et à mulhouse dans un bâtiment
précis et je sais quel bâtiment
j'avais fait apparaître
l'automatique via l'application pour
quand la personne ouvrir et le mac avec
mon numéro de téléphone etc
non pas tellement rappelé mais je vais
jouer le corps léger parce que je sais
qu'on va récupérer ce match je sais
qu'on va le retrouver qu'on n'aura pas
de problème tout d'abord avec joachim on
a fait le point sur qui était dans le
wagon avec nous à ce moment là qu'ils
étaient descendus
il restait pas grand monde à nous deux
on a pu visualiser qu'elles étaient des
personnes les personnes âgées il y avait
un jeune et c'est qu'on s'est refait les
entrées et les sorties des personnes qui
étaient sortis avant nous apprennent ou
du train et le seul suspect potentiel
était un jeune qui avaient une vingtaine
d'années il a ouvert l'ordinateur juste
avant que je joue donc à peu près à
20h20 20h25
ça collait pas avec notre heure
d'arrivée qui était de 14 heures pour
moi à 20 ans tu trouves un mac à 14h tu
attends pas à 20h30 pour essayer de voir
s'il fonctionne ça colle par contre si
c'est quelqu'un qui travaille et qui va
attendre de rentrer chez lui pour
pouvoir l'ouvrir et d'un coup tous les
soupçons se portent sur les personnes
qui font le ménage dans le train et on
part donc sur cette piste là sur l'idée
que c'est quelqu'un qui travaille dans
ce train je vous rappelle que grâce à la
localisation que j'avais eus durant
quelques secondes
la veille à 20h20 j'avais un bâtiment
très précis qui est destituée dans
mulhouse donc partant donc à midi à ce
fameux bâtiment pour trouver mon mac
potentiellement on arrive donc sur un
quartier un papa le quartier bourgeois
on va pas se mentir c'est plutôt à un
quartier un petit peu hlm de gens dehors
ça a l'air sympathique et tout ok je
j'identifie bien le bâtiment j'ai de la
chance parce que y'a que douze
appartements dans le bâtiment je garde
l'idée de la piste que c'est quelqu'un
qui travaillait dans le train et qui
faisait le ménage du train et je frappe
à la première porte c'est une c'est une
femme qui m'ouvre et là je suis fait
vraiment au culot je dis bonjour excusez
moi j'ai eu votre adresse par la sncf
c'est bien vous qui travaillez dans les
trains ou votre mari en fait je sais pas
j'ai pas très très bien compris et la
femme me dit que non voile du tout
qu'elle travaille pas du tout aller cncf
et j'insiste vraiment alors pourquoi on
m'a donné cette adresse enfin c'est
quand même
ou alors ou alors c'est peut-être pas
votre appartement il ya quelqu'un qui
travaille ici à la sncf dans ce cas là
je me suis peut-être juste aux plantes
et de portes
c'est le fameux moment où elle nous dira
oui oui c'est vrai on a un voisin qui
travaille à la sncf
alors je sais pas qu'elle porte c'est en
fait on se croise plus tôt devant mais
oui il ya un monsieur dans le bâtiment
qui travaillent là tu dis donc c'est pas
magique ça je continue mon porte-à-porte
avec une personne au dessus qui
m'accueillait un petit peu avec méfiance
et puis quand j'explique on m'a donné
l'adresse et puis que c'est un monsieur
qui travaillent là qui équipa très très
vieux qu'à une quarantaine d'années il
se détend il cherche avec moi il fait
bon allez demander à la jeune fille qui
emballe connais tout le monde ici je
descends pour parler de la jeune fille
qui en bas qui tourne connaît tout le
monde ici sauf le mec que cherche et là
je vois un mec qui sort de chez lui il
jette un regard vers moi il rejette un
regarde vers sa porte
donc il est en train de faire un choix
une hésitation je fonce sur lui devant
tous ses voisins
au milieu de tout le monde je veux voir
dira enfin je le trouve c'est bien vous
de monsieur la sncf car récupérer
l'ordinateur pour que vienne le chercher
si c'est pas lui c'est pas grave je
risque pas grand chose en l'occurrence
c'est bien mais qu de la sncf il peut
que assumer devant tous les voisins et
en plus j'ai déjà parlé de l'objet de ma
présence venir récupérer l'ordinateur on
peut monter chez lui dans son entrée
dans son hall d'entrée et me dis je vais
à la chambre et je reviens me dit on va
éviter de se faire tuer quand même
qu'ils reviennent avec un physio jeu oui
bah écoutez c'est aux employeurs qu'ils
m'ont donné votre adresse directement
ils m'ont dit que c'est vous qui l'aviez
donc comme nous on habite juste à côté
c'était plus simple de passer quoi là il
ya eu la petite phrase magnifique la
petite phrase de trop d'ailleurs qui a
été de dire vous avez de la chance que
ça tombe sur moi quand même hein ça
aurait pu tomber sur quelqu'un de
malhonnête
bah c'est ce qu'était mon pote quand
même parce que tu t'es barré avec
l'ordinateur
c'est quand même pas très grave au front
n'essayez pas d'avoir plus de
remerciement quand même parce que je
suis en train de faire bref je récupère
le mac à ce moment là on repart
joachim on attend d'être vraiment
vraiment vraiment éloigné pour ouvrir le
mcee devoir qui fonctionne et que tout
va bien et on a récupéré pour la petite
anecdote croustillante de l'histoire on
est allé déposer des fly et des
invitations pour le spectacle mais le
même spectacle que je voulais à fabien
olicard augmente à lise juste pour
qu'ils sachent comment on avait remonté
jusqu'à lui c'est une petite
satisfaction personnelle dans cette
histoire de ouf on m'avait demandé de
parler d'une avec d'autres nous est
demandé de parler potentiellement mes
voyages en trains vous m'a demandé de
parler de la tournée est bien dans ce
que je lis je fais ce que je veux
j'aurai réussi à réunir les trois si
cette petite histoire vous a plu vous
pouvez aussi le faire savoir en mettant
housse en l'air vous pouvez également
commenter je vis tous les messages vous
pouvez aussi vous abonner à la chaîne et
rendez vous de demain 17h pour charmante
anne roghe ciao